nos preguntan cuántas pulgadas hay en
cuatro y media yardas okay tenemos dos
formas de hacer este problema un es ver
cuantas pulgadas hay en cuatro yardas
cuántas hay en media yarda y después
sumar o bien podemos transformar este
cuatro y un medio a una fracción
impropia y trabajar a partir de ahí pero
antes de empezar con cualquiera de estas
formas déjame pensar en cuántas pulgadas
hay en cada yarda entonces vamos a
empezar con una yarda una yarda y
sabemos cómo convertir yardas a pies y
piezas pulgadas así que vamos a hacer
esto por pasos una yarda primero la
vamos a convertir en pies entonces
tenemos que dividir entre yardas para
que se cancelen aquí le voy a poner
yardas la verdad y tenemos que
multiplicar por pies y aquí tenemos que
dar la conversión cuántos cuántos pies
hay en una yarda pues hay tres esto ya
lo vimos hay tres pies en una yarda vale
los pies son unidades más chiquitas
entonces tiene sentido que haya tres
pies en una yarda
aquí las yardas se cancelan con yardas
el uno con el uno es un uno de tal forma
que una yarda es igual a tres
tres pies excelente ahora vamos a pasar
de pies a pulgadas resulta que cada pie
tiene 12 pulgadas entonces déjame poner
aquí abajo pies pies y aquí arriba voy a
poner pulgadas pulgadas vale entonces un
pie tiene 12 pulgadas y de esta forma
ahora pie se cancela con pies y nos
queda 3 por 12 que es igual a 36 36
pulgadas pulgadas vale entonces a lo
mejor ya lo puedes leer de aquí pero
déjame escribirlo para que se vea más
claro con esto concluimos que una yarda
yarda
una yarda es igual a 36 pulgadas vale un
garage
muy bien con esta información ya podemos
resolver este problema de dos formas
vamos a hacerlo primero viendo cuántas
cuantas pulgadas hay en cuatro yardas y
en media yarda y sumamos vale después
vemos la segunda forma entonces déjame
empezar con este color rosa entonces
empecemos con cuatro con cuatro yardas
cuatro yardas muy bien entonces para
hacer la conversión de yardas a pulgadas
ya tenemos esta esta forma de convertir
entonces vamos a multiplicar por 36
pulgadas 36 pulgadas
y tenemos que dividir entre yardas /
yardas entre una yarda
y al realizar las operaciones nos queda
nos queda 4 por 36 las yardas se
cancelan con yardas y pues vamos a hacer
la operación por acá a ver 36 x 4 nos da
6 por 4 de 24 llevamos 24 por 13 12 y 2
que llevamos es 14 14 144 entonces 4
yardas son 144 144 pulgadas pulgadas
entonces déjame marcar con morado este 4
que es lo que acabamos de hacer y ahora
voy a pasar este color azul para hacer
la media yarda que nos falta entonces
ahora vamos a hacer media yarda
tenemos que multiplicar por la misma
conversión la conversión es 36 pulgadas
por yardas pulgadas
por yarda la verdad
ya está y entonces vamos a multiplicar
misma idea yardas se cancela con yarda
un medio por 36 es lo mismo que hacer 36
entre 2 así que nos queda 18 pulgadas
públicas y simplemente tenemos que
tenemos que sumar estas dos vale
entonces déjame hacer la suma por acá
entonces vamos a sumar 144 o sea porque
cuatro y media yardas son cuatro yardas
más media yarda entonces hay que sumar
144 pulgadas con 18 pulgadas 18 pulgadas
que es suma 8 y 4 es 12 llevamos una una
y 45 y unas 6 y este 1 baja entonces nos
queda déjame ponerlo con un color así
más notorio con rojo nos queda 162 162
pulgadas
muy bien entonces estoy aquí ya sería la
respuesta aquí parece aquí se púrpuras
entonces a ponerle otra vez pulgadas
pulgadas muy bien entonces estoy aquí ya
sería la respuesta pero vamos a ver cómo
se puede hacer de otra forma este
problema vale ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es convertir esta fracción mixta mixta
en una fracción impropia lo voy a hacer
de este lado entonces vamos a
transformar cuatro y un medio en una
fracción en una fracción impropia cuatro
y un medio cuatro y un medio es lo mismo
que cuatro más un medio simplemente es
una forma más sencilla de escribir
cuatro más un medio y aquí podemos hacer
una suma de fracciones este 4 lo
pensamos como un 4 entre 1 hay que sumar
un medio hay que encontrar ahora hay que
encontrar ahora un denominador común que
sería 2 entonces aquí hay que
multiplicar este 1 por 2 el 4 también se
multiplica por 2 nos queda 8 1 y
finalmente estudian esto de aquí es
igual a 9 medios y quizás aquí hice
demasiados pasos pero es para que te
quede muy claro cómo se puede obtener 9
medios si quieres una regla para
abreviar te tantas cuentas simplemente
puedes hacer 4
por 28 19 y entonces quedan 9 medios
pero de aquí viene vale bueno entonces
ya sabemos que 4 con un medio son 9
medios de esta forma ahora lo único que
tenemos que hacer es convertir nueve
medios nueve medios de yarda nueve a
nueve mitades de yarda nueve medias
yardas y utilizamos esta unidad de esta
forma de conversión
entonces multiplicamos por 36 pulgadas
pulgadas y dividimos entre yardas tres
yardas y entonces vamos a ver cuánto nos
queda a ver aquí las yardas se cancelan
una vez más nos quedan nueve por 36
entre 29 por 36 36 entre dos pulgadas
pulgadas
aquí pues hay que simplificar esto un
poco hay varias formas de hacerlo pero
creo que lo mejor es dividir entre dos
el numerador y el denominador para que
se simplifica un poco el numerador
entonces dividiendo entre 2 nos quedan 9
por 18 y 36 entre 12 y 18 / / 12 / 21
pulgadas pulgadas que es lo mismo que 9
por 18 vamos a hacer la operación 9 por
18 por acá haber 18 por 9 mejor 18 por 9
9 por 8 72 2 y llevamos 7 9 por 19 y 7
que llevamos son 16 10 y 662 entonces
aquí nos queda igual a 162 pulgadas que
'afortunadamente pulgadas
afortunadamente es exactamente lo mismo
que encontramos con el otro método vale
bueno entonces 4 yardas y media son 162
pulgadas